[Music]
this is a captain told the bleach 41
people be tested positive for
coronavirus it's never gonna happen to
me it couldn't happen to me that's what
me and my friends were saying on the
ship oh please stay inside you
staterooms and do not go outside
obviously you just feel desperate but
you're at sea who's gonna let us
disembark I don't think that they were
terribly transparent about what they
knew when they knew it
Carnival is worse the biggest cruise
ship company in the world and since this
began their ships more than any other
companies have been struck by these
outbreaks of covet on board
hundreds of passengers on these ships
have been infected and some have even
died and Bloomberg Businessweek has been
reporting in depth on what went wrong
and what's next for Carnival navigating
this very challenging crisis
[Music]
On February 3rd the diamond princess was
around the coast of Japan it had made
stops in Hong Kong it had gone to Taiwan
and elsewhere was supposed to be our
last night on the cruise we were
supposed to get off the next morning
around 6:30 that night an announcement
comes throughout the entire ship tested
positive for coronavirus
as you can see this is the situation
that's really when we knew that we
probably were not getting off the ship
that next morning so the ship cruises
toward Japan and finally anchors in the
evening of February 3rd at that point
carnival says the Japanese health
officials came aboard and started doing
temperature checks health screenings
unfortunately according to passengers
this wasn't a really serious quarantine
on a passenger said that they were free
to go about the ship my cabin mate and
the other two guys that we were
traveling with who were in the cabin
next door they they went out and they
had a grand old time that day you know
as most people did eating in the
restaurants watching the live house
bands eventually they find out that
there is actually cause for concern
[Music]
tested positive for echovirus we have
confirmed 10 positive cases and based on
this we are going to quarantine the
entire ship for a minimum of 14 days so
that that's when it officially began we
are currently in the middle of day 2
above the quarantine
it is currently day 3 apparently 41 new
cases on the ship there are 38 new
people who have tested positive 44 new
cases 66 positive cases we continue to
see the numbers go up every single day
it was an emotional rollercoaster in the
end more than 700 people were infected
and tragically at least 11 people ended
up dying and this was just the beginning
of the crisis for his company
I want to highlight one of the most
impressive turnaround stories of our era
if not the most impressive turnaround
I've talked about carnival CCL the
world's largest cruise line are you
bigger than the US Navy you know that's
a good question I never compared numbers
of ships but I doubt it the cruise
industry is is really massive Carnival
Cruise they say they see about 13
million people annually this is a
booming market the people love to cruise
we've probably done two dozen cruises
sometimes we've done 2 or 3 in a year
for lucky cruises are the perfect
combination between being convenient
being affordable and allowing you to
just relax and you pack once to unpack
once your hotel moves with you your
restaurant moves with you
Carnival is specifically they own about
thirty to fifty percent of the market
there were annual revenue amounts to
about twenty billion dollars more
recently Carnival has run into some
troubles you might have seen them in the
news in the 2010s they had a boat that
capsized and actually sunk and killing
about 30 people and then later on they
had a very high-profile incident in
which they lost power on the ship and
none of the plumbing worked but under
Arnold Donald who was the current CEO of
Carnival they've undergone an a
remarkable turnaround since about 2013
the more we give people the opportunity
to connect and experience the world
together the more spectacular our world
will be you saw the market cap in the
first five years under his tenure
essentially doubled to about fifty
billion dollars ironically leading into
this whole crisis that we've seen you
had Arnold Donald promising that he was
actually gonna correct things he had a
plan in place to fix all these shortcuts
that Carnival had historically been
taking our tasks our mission
double-digit return invested capital
next week for you well I want to
congratulate you on the
book turn the whole trend has been up
[Music]
after the diamond princess ship about a
month passes and then another ship the
Grand Princess they deal with
essentially the same crisis we boarded
the ship in in San Francisco and we we
did think there would be a little more
enhanced screening because of what had
happened on the diamond princess at a
minimum we thought they would have at
least taken our temperature as we
boarded this ship but that that never
happened and things just kind of
exploded on our way home the first
tester ring and the coronavirus is on
board the Grand Princess the Coast Guard
delivered tests in dramatic fashion and
21 people tested positive for the virus
it just kind of escalated quickly
quickly they you know sequestered us to
our rooms and delivered food to us in
our rooms and obviously that was a major
shock of something's wrong so like the
diamond princess in Japan which they
sailed immediately back to port the
Grand Prince was headed back to their
homeport of San Francisco 3,500 people
stuck on that cruise ship off the coast
of California they will finally be
coming ashore all passengers and crew
will be tested for the corona virus
those that need to be quarantined will
be quarantined in the end it proved a
much smaller outbreak than the diamond
princess but that's most likely because
not everyone chose to get tested in the
end more than 130 people tested positive
and at least five passed away
as these issues are happening aboard the
Grand Princess another ship owned by a
different Carnival Cruise Line which is
Holland Americas and am is sailing
around the cruise basically set sail
more or less the same day that the US
State Department warned people not to be
going on cruises and the company just
forged ahead with the cruise for some
reason they decided to keep going life
was good that first week everything was
great but I saw a friend's picture about
having issues getting toilet paper and
other things I was kind of concerned as
to how this was gonna play out
March 14th the ship received word that
Chile was planning to close its ports to
any cruise ship and from then on out
that ship was at sea with nowhere to
port on March 22nd the captain came on
the announcement and said we have people
sick with a flu-like illness everybody's
got to be confined to their quarters the
whole ship's going into quarantine March
22nd was kind of a I guess a different
feel it didn't feel like a cruise
anymore sometimes I sat out on a deck at
night and I would just listen to the
waves now sadly sometimes I listened
also to a cascade of people coughing
after everybody was confined to quarters
for a few days the captain came on the
announcements said you know we're sorry
to report that four people have passed
away over the last couple of days so
many crew on the Zaandam were getting
sick that they were having trouble
taking care of all the passengers and so
the company made the decision to bring
in another ship called the Rotterdam
they started ferrying passengers five
six seven hundred passengers who seemed
to be less sick they put
so now they had two ships full of
passengers that could not come to Port
Panama didn't even want them to go
through the canal finally the Panamanian
government decided after all to let them
go through the canal and that's what
happened both those ships pass through
the canal and they slowly made their way
back to Florida after days at sea and
with their fate up in the air a pair of
Holland America cruise ships were given
clearance to dock at Port Everglades
Thursday afternoon yay we're back home
back to the States there were quite a
number of people that were actually sick
and they were taken to hospitals and of
course there were those four people who
had passed away that had to be taken
home or find a way home we've gone
through Ebola zika MERS SARS the
industry because we're global we have to
deal with this stuff you know it's been
devastating temporarily but the
long-term future will be great as long
as we all stand together so since this
crisis began Carnival its business has
really been suffering we've seen its
stock really plummet quite significantly
we spent weeks talking to company
executives and the company was really
upbeat and positive if not defiant the
CEO Arnold Donald kept saying look back
when this first affected our first ship
the world still hadn't known about
coronavirus yet it was still in his
words that was still a China issue we
talked to the CDC we talked to the head
of their cruise ship task force dr.
Cindy Friedman and she said that excuse
does not fly it would be one thing if it
was only aboard the diamond princess or
even the Grand Princess those first two
ships but the fact that this crisis
continued to affect Carnival afterward
essentially Carnival should have known
better I look forward to cruising again
one day but you know I realize the
paradigm has changed it's very easy to
say whatever cruise again but I'm
wondering well what's the world gonna
look like where we ever be going to a
concert or sporting event
yeah it's not just cruise one thing that
I do agree with Arnold Donald on he said
this is an unprecedented generational
global event and I think that's totally
spot-on and in the years ahead we're
gonna look back and we're gonna see who
responded to that generational crisis
well and who did not
you